- [Kelly Clarkson] So wait,
So wasn't there a time that you wore,
this is brilliant to me.
You wore the same outfit pretty
much for like six months.
- [Daniel Radcliffe] Yeah, for,
I think it wasn't quite that
but it was like three or four months,
Cause I was doing a play in London,
and every night there was
like paparazzi outside.
And I suddenly realized after like,
I had just been lazy and
not changed my clothes
for a few days,
that they were not there.
And I realized that they,
oh it's probably because
I'm wearing the same thing
so it all looks like
photos from the same day.
So then I was just like, I'll
just continue wearing this.
And they never came back.
- Because, it looks like the same picture.
- [Daniel Radcliffe] It all
looks like the same picture
- [Kelly Clarkson] You have just like,
cured a lot of people's issues right now.
- It's not foolproof that,
you know, there's still you know,
it didn't solve everything.
but it was good, any,
I feel like, you know-
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's not as Exciting.
- The small victories of paparazzi
is always the ones you
have to like celebrate.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's a Giant one!
I thought you were brilliant.
- Thank you very much.
- I'm Stealing-
- A friend also got me a jacket once
which is like, made out
of reflective material
so if someone takes a flash photo-
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh and it shines?
- It just like flashes
out the entire thing.
- But meanwhile you
look like a disco ball,
like everywhere you go, that's awesome.
- Yes, it's as cool as
something like that can look,
but it's function is something else.
- Okay, okay,
'Cause I just pictured you
just dancing everywhere
you're going in this jacket.
That's what I wanted.